me
i feel like it might not be
darkness
you better make sure
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but anyways
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a few things before we get started
please stay off your cell phones no
heckling you keep tabletop to a minimum
now who's ready to see other people
he's awesomely dating he's a regular on
kill tony
uh out of towner from new york city
which is like this city only way bigger
and some would say
way better
um new york city
killer
she's also asian and hilarious as [ __ ]
and also she's like really fast and
she's sort of urban she's like the urban
asian i'm like the the white asian she's
sort of urban asian give it up for
hoorah for surah surah
surah in the house
how you doing surah yo yo yo i gotta
live up to the urban asian
what's going on everybody
[ __ ]
feeling good
yeah everybody's feeling good
i got that fresh off the plane crusty
feel you know you guys know yeah after
flying all day she's about to do the
baby wipes i saw you some face masks
from korea
i need a face mask he's going to sell
you some boba tea
is that even korean huh
i think we're being racist against
ourselves right now i know
we got to do it before they do it to us
these goddamn texans they're sharp with
their racism they've been honing it for
years
um
so this is a fun show where we watch
people date uh how's your dating life
been overall
i mean i'm doing it
oh thank you for doing it that's you
know it's just putting yourself out
there is a lot you know that's
you know that's all we can ask
um you know i don't know what is that a
weird thing to say did i just say
something sexist what
thank you for putting yourself out there
and this is a woman's bucket
yeah
we got a man named grant coming up here
grant
wow what a tall tall man wow your hair
you obviously came here to work out you
look like a ken doll man you got i know
you should hear him talking he's so
boring
uh and then the woman
we got
anna where's she at anna and
that's her potato
they're going on a date with
people they came on a date with
what a weird concept oh wow
oh wow welcome back
pulling the chair out touch in the back
now he's is he tucking the chair in he
tucked it a little bit in
i didn't get a good look give it up for
grant and anna they're going on a date
it's so nice to see you again how are
you hey i'm good how are you awesome
thanks for taking the second date with
me yeah obviously i'm putting a lot of
effort into it right now um i've been
curious like have you been on any great
vacations lately um
not late you know actually i went on a
disney cruise a month ago
but it wasn't great
well kind of
i drink a lot because that's the only
thing you can do at a disney cruises you
got to kill all the germs yeah just
furmanating in that place yeah
how about you uh me i just got back from
dallas i went to uh surprise a buddy for
his 31st birthday party and it got a
little crazy cool
yeah uh have you ever been up to dallas
at concrete cowboy um
not in dallas i've been to dallas that's
a concrete cowboy yeah it's less
stripper poles than the one here in
austin
but a lot more strippers
it's a little weird but is it less fun
or more fun
you know what i was frightened honestly
there was i was actually assaulted at
the bar okay
yeah was that fun or not um
i was a little scared at first okay
someone just randomly grabbed my ass
and uh that's hot
give it up for grant and anna
he went on a date yeah he talked about
strippers and ass grabbing
i don't know if you want to bring that
up right away did you like the ass play
grant
um you know at first i was a little uh
surprised but
um
you know i just had to appreciate it i
guess
was it a woman or a man uh it was a very
firm grip so i thought it was a man at
first but i turned around and it was a
small woman
and i was just like wow you've you're
pretty powerful maybe she bit you
she could have she had a strong jawline
do you have a good ass i would i would
think that you are so white that your
ass would be as flat as it is uh let's
see that ass i've been working on it but
see that oh it's not bad how do i stand
to make
what is another red flag that you've
noticed uh talking about strippers
telling him about that
what about you grand you think the
disney cruise is a little red flaggish
yeah i have little siblings
so okay i
wasn't my fault or anything yeah i
didn't expect to go to disney cruise for
new year's
yeah you don't you did get a covet test
before you came here right yeah okay
cool like three disney strain is so this
is yours this is another red flag
accusing your date of having germs
second date like our date or like second
time here this is our second date here
oh really this is your second time this
is the only way you can get hurt yeah
like he doesn't talk to me off stage he
doesn't talk to you yeah
this is a show couple they're just
celebrities yeah
you guys just really want to be in the
bachelorette or whatever yeah they're
being fed lines right now their their
look falls apart off stage it's just a
costume that they're all wearing
um
you uh went on a disney cruise uh like
what does that mean does that mean like
they do like musicals there like people
are dressed up like tinkerbell yeah
samson
a lot of trivia
and bingo
trivia
my highlight was i took a mixology class
okay so here's the question i know that
cruises you know there's a lot of sex
going on is there a lot of
sex going on was there disney sex cruise
sex a lot of role plays yeah another
person my age except for my older
brother do you think the people who
dress as characters have sex with each
other really concerned that's the thing
that's called fluffy right like coffee
furry hurry
fluffy is a very funny comedian
kind of annoying but you're like very in
your face like you just want to eat and
they're just like smiling and talking to
you and i'm like i just want to chill
theater majors am i right they're the
worst
there's a whole boatload full of them
and you went on it
i mean that's what kids like so it is
mainly geared
yeah i mean you'd be great as a mulan um
you look like it's the only one i could
play actually
my options are limited
they don't have an asian do they have
anything
the new uh movie the dragon one the last
dragon oh you got it
that's southeast asian you'd have to get
a tan oh
um you could do
but they don't have any asian disney
characters for men do they
shang chi that's that's marvel oh they
got kung fu panda
but yeah not a lot of roles for asian
men
besides you know ball fluffer and
cuck wait what cruise are you on
this is the difference this is a way
better cruise on the disney cruise it
doesn't sound like anyone is [ __ ]
there and when it is it's like a sex
crime it's like you know like you got to
get arrested for that [ __ ] you don't
want to have sex on a disney cruise uh
but grant
have you ever been on a cruise or did
you just look like this no i i just
naturally look like i've been
worn through on a boat i mean like
i want to go on a cruise but what does
that mean worn through you're just
passing around just sailing
yeah just too much sun drinking and old
ladies grabbing my ass probably playing
too much shuffle was uh this lady the
small petite lady that grabbed you with
the force of a thousand men
was she attractive or was she no
uh and i didn't know how to respond i'm
like
did i just walk away should i like
like this was basically sexual assault
yeah and i was trying to think like what
if this was the reverse and i was just
confused and you know
if you were grabbing her ass yeah of
course like this would go down way
differently i'd be thrown out by five
guys but yeah is that why you're here
right now you need therapy
okay i did want to get some advice on
this like so
someone you don't find attractive i mean
grabs you so you're you're not into it
what do you do
like as a man in that situation well
you're six foot two i'm guessing so uh
you punch her in the face
advocating for hitting women this is a
progressive
we're all equal
uh grant um
i mean i would say take the compliment
and move on
not a big deal welcome to 2022.
yeah
hey this guy with a chinstrap mustache
is telling you how to be a man
i think he just officially adopted you
by the laws of texas
actually 25 years old or something yeah
that's about right yeah i uh no that's
that's pretty much how it went uh but
she wanted me to buy her a drink and i'm
like you got to grab my ass
and you want
to go to a strip club it wasn't a strip
club it was a bar but it just looked
like a strip club the way this place was
run
saturday night grant's got to put on his
navy blue slacks
red flag what is the numbers on the side
of your shirt are you in squid game or
what's going on here the zip code for
you yeah it's like the zip code right
yeah yeah you're actually right it's the
zip code for the gym ford strength
austin on southwest nerd he's doing
taxes on his shirt
[Music]
this guy is so white he's just always
doing paperwork
yeah
anna what do you think about grant as a
sexual being you think that uh he's got
a lot of charisma yeah he's cool
where uh where did you guys meet
um
he's not here cosmic yeah we met at
cosmic first before we made our way all
the way down to creaking cave the first
time so you met at a bar
friday night sixth street park coffee
shop yeah
it's a bar
it's like yeah you actually met like
what was the pickup line
and then i wanted to take her somewhere
where we could have a nice such a cop
out basically he was saying he wanted to
take her someone cheap he didn't want to
buy her dinner
[ __ ] coffee bought her some tea
three dollars max
you want a skunker so
what uh what is what is like the best
date you the best first date you've been
on where you're like damn this was like
this is great
don't just say that because grant is
here he doesn't have disney cruise money
i don't have a gun under the table i
actually have a cool one
but like i saw this guy once he was from
france and i never saw him again
that's how the french are there
no like it was like i knew i wasn't
going to see him again and he invited me
to two comedy shows
which is cool
that worked dude
i could get you into three comedy shows
[Laughter]
that's hard for me to compete with right
there no i mean he wasn't like a fun
dude
but
yeah he was french like we didn't even
talk we were at shows
his accent didn't carry the comments
french accents did you guys french after
that
no
we're the comedian i mean it was like a
fun day i like the guy was in fun
so everything around the guys yeah yeah
he needs his fringe card revoked if he
couldn't like close the deal that's
supposed to be their whole thing is well
i didn't want to yeah
well that's cool you went on a date with
a guy who's with no one here a good guy
but now you're here with grant
that's why the bar was so low
that's why coffee was our best date
comedy shows who goes to comedy so
what's like something that grant has
done for you where you're like
that was kind of cool and not a lot of
people do it and it's probably goes
unnoticed
oh yeah so that's a fake that's a fake
blonde yes it's a fake one it's a good
fake blonde thank you is yours a real
grant
i hope so
it looks real thank you i appreciate
that no it's uh
it's fun to be blonde isn't it it's yeah
how long have you been blonde for um
since i was 17
so that's like five years
you're committed to it 22
yeah [ __ ] so who you are before i was 17
what
what
two blondes on a date
um what do you guys talk about like uh
croquet or like
okay
isn't that like that
like putt-putt golf but you like step on
the ball indian people that was my next
state idea [ __ ] that's fun cricket oh
what's croquet
is that in that [ __ ]
paddleboarding i confused it with polo
oh
no i still don't know what we're talking
about
croquet
you guys seem like the whitest couple
ever but you're mexican apparently um
yeah
um so yeah you guys are a beautiful
couple overall you know like uh thank
you for coming again it's crazy that you
got called up twice um
where do you think you guys are going to
go on a date next croquet sounds good
now we could do or golf or golf yeah she
does love the golf so that's another one
you're a golfer yeah that's awesome
she's more white than you are she wanna
be disney
what's the whitest thing you've done
grant
oh god
i have to go through my daily like
routine
that's
the widest thing i've ever done is go to
a skillet concert like a christian rock
band
that's the probably the widest thing
you guys know have you ever been in a
monster before either of you that's
probably another really white thing
actually i have you have yeah how'd that
go well i'm here but it was hard to be
here
yeah you kicked some ass on said you're
really urban so did you like shank
someone i just uh kung food my way out
of it
yeah she has hollow bones she it's like
a beach ball it's like she go it's like
yeah i just said put me up and then i
mock and then i crowd surf my way out of
it hell yeah have you ever been in a
mosh pit
no or like a bar fight or some crazy
thing breaks out and you just like we're
shooting on sixth street usually
yeah
not the shooting part but yeah i've seen
them i've never been in one
yeah well that's cool you listen to
christian rock music so
you know he loves me
okay i hope that you guys have a lot of
great missionary sex tonight hey it's uh
and that's why he likes to ask play so
much he's trying to save it for jesus
[Laughter]
he's still a virgin ladies
he's not put his penis in anything he's
just been penetrated by unattractive
women in dallas
give it up for grant and anna thank you
grand nanna
[Applause]
all right they went on a date
i hope that uh they're doing fine yeah
even though i feel like they're treating
these as therapy sessions already
they didn't um
reveal anything too shocking besides his
rampant sex uh strip club uh addiction
i got another anna what is there another
anna in the house oh you probably put it
back in the bucket that's the same
writing con i have no idea what's going
on
i'm sorry i shouldn't have done that
[Music]
and also
wait there's another girl this is a girl
this sounds like a girl this is the
lgbtq bucket let's do lgbtq next okay uh
sorry this is the man bucket right here
men i crossed out the f
this is sahar zarahi ayolam
going on a date with with
rodney smith
where you at rodney
there he comes from the back
with the red hat on shoot welcome
welcome thank you
sarah are we saying your name right no
no one's telling my name right so
we're okay
how do you say it
sahari yes i'm from mexico
silence
the h is silent let's hope
her date is rodney smith let the woman
talk for once why not uh sarah
ayolm and rodney smith one minute date
where's your name again my name's rodney
okay i'm so sorry i cannot pronounce
that name i kind of like your accent a
lot oh man
why all other people say the same to me
like
i'm i'm literally super afraid right now
for my accent because all these people
is looking at me no it's great trust me
thank you yeah um this is very
counter-intuitive for me by the way
because usually when i have a microphone
in my hand my purpose is to be as mean
as possible
so uh but you're very beautiful and i'm
very excited to be up here with you so
oh thank you yeah so this is different
usually i'm trying to find something uh
really [ __ ] up about somebody's face
or what they're wearing and talk about
it but so this is a very pleasant
experience oh okay so you're trying to
find like something someone different to
me like
oh no usually just when i'm telling
jokes you know i've never been on a date
on stage before with uh
with a seltzer this is my first time too
so it's kind of weird because all these
people is listening to us there's a
first time for everything i don't know
why what should i say in front of these
people like where are you from or what
but um
yeah i don't know so are your jokes
pretty mean or are they like just
observations about airplane food
i could be mean
nah they're pretty mean you know usually
uh things you probably shouldn't say
are you a nice person or yeah yeah i'm a
really nice person it's a front it's
human psychology that we all put out
this image to protect our inner core you
know when you meet like a really big
buff roided out guy he's actually
usually kind of very sensitive so i'm a
really mean person because i'm actually
very i'm actually uh kind of a sensitive
guy i know i'm uh really intimidating
physically in my presence
can cause shock and awe but uh
if you get to know me i'm really a softy
is that what those tattoos are about
rodney you're just you know trying to
pretend like you're hard but you know i
really regret this tattoo because uh i
wanted something european so i got a
masquerade girl because there was like
these festivals because i grew up in
germany and then so i've never seen a
mother he's a nazi
yeah that explains the blue eye i am
usually very mean to the jews i mean the
audience everybody asked me if it's
[ __ ] catwoman and i didn't i don't
i've never even seen batman so i really
regret this town so were you a military
brat
yeah
where did you grow up dusseldorf
that's it is a real place but it sounds
made up for some reason
i grew up in frankfurt i grew up in like
the atlanta sausage
yeah i know i'm sorry i didn't call you
gay um no that's awesome he's uh from
the military sarahi
how does that make you feel he could
kill you and or he could kill your
enemies in 500 different ways
i don't think he's dangerous for all to
be honest i don't think he can kill
someone he's saying you're soft
she say you're a millennial you can
treat fat americans who got coveted
um thank you for being here you're from
mexico where in mexico
that's uh actually where the disney
cruise went
to monterey that's where that's the
jasmine was actually a mexican lady from
monterey
but uh you're from monterey uh you know
how how is it over there you guys got a
lot of uh a lot of mountains first and a
lot of crazy people like new york too so
it's like
you said like new jersey like new york
oh okay it's kind of new york you can
find crazy people on the street so it's
like see no wonder she thinks i'm a
[ __ ] she comes from cartel land
oh [ __ ] he just calls your country a
[ __ ] no i didn't call it a [ __ ]
but is it the cartel is very prevalent
monterey am i uh am i mistaken there
have i watched too much tv
well
you can't say it again no it's not like
you're going to mexico and someone is
going to kill you of course no it's but
you can find
places but she knows killers very crazy
people i mean someone can kill you if
you are having a bad business with them
but if you don't have bad business with
them you're fine it's like or maybe if
you're right someone can kill you
you can't go to their whole foods and
try to return a broccoli anymore
it's bad business i was just looking for
a cop out because she said i was a [ __ ]
so
well you know that's awesome you know uh
monterrey you know [ __ ] awesome
have you been
rodney would burst into flames if he
went to mexico three years oh okay all
right
cool well rodney you looking to sponsor
um
her week her visa
i think you're very beautiful and very
funny and have a very great personality
but i'm extremely anti-marriage so i
will not be able to help you out with
that one
whoa he's anti-marriage i don't need
that so don't worry and also i'm not
trying to find a relationship because i
have a boyfriend already
i know you guys are from mexico
um but uh yeah i mean have you ever
dated a
you know caucasian before gringo
yes
she reluctantly said yes
what happened what happened
oh wow this is so toxic
toxic toxic none of them but almost all
of them i'm so curious please keep going
well
[Music]
does he eat ass do white people eat ass
why they are obsessed with the eggs i
don't understand it's a blaster
like ex-girlfriends oh yeah they're
they're very prideful people mine so
that's that's that's yeah they are crazy
so sometimes i'm like i'm here just to
have a healthy relationship and they are
like no i want drama in the relationship
that is a thing so the only healthy
relationship i've ever had was with an
artin
uh or girl from argentina wow i sound
really racist not being able to yeah
that was the most healthy she was so
nice she was so kind but her visa
expired and you know i was you got to
send her back
come here legally [ __ ]
yeah all the all the white girls were
troubled
what's your boyfriend now is he oh he's
from austin
he's white or yeah it's very white what
you give the one example of the
shittiest white man you dated why not
you're correct i really like white guys
because they are so handsome
to be honest you're handsome thank
same you like kind of like toxic people
it's like they like drama they like to
fight all the time it's like man i work
all day i don't want to come here and
fight with you
but you do you dating women
there's no drama with them they're not
always yelling at you just go straight
to stabbing you they don't
yeah they don't bother arguing they just
get into it they'll smell something on
you and then stab you
that's latino woman
um but uh yeah i mean um
you're dating a white man now
yes i do but he's so nice oh that's
awesome you found a softie
we found one of the good ones um
rodney
who's like the most exotic racial person
you've dated like have you dated a
tongan or like uh
like a mozambique
this is showing how racist i am because
i don't know what tongan is um
like i guess yeah the girl from
argentina that was definitely argentina
yeah
the whitest latin american country
that any time he says something racist
no i i dated a girl from argentina i
swear but i just made that i can say the
n word i dated a girl from argentina
exactly
i've never actually never dated a blonde
woman now they think about it it's
always been brunettes so that's pretty
spicy to me i guess yeah you can't have
two blonde women in the relationship
yeah
yeah i need to i need to straighten out
my genetics because you know if i if i
breed with another blonde person then
the kid's gonna get called powder and
pasty face all its life as well what's
the meanest thing someone said to you
because you're white um you know i i've
experienced so much racism growing up
but no literally i used to think about
that a lot growing up because there
wasn't a single day in my life in like
elementary school when i because i'm
actually from germany so when i moved
here every day be like oh dude you're so
pasty oh you're so white oh you [ __ ]
kraut you german everybody just laugh
you know like okay if anybody looked any
different than me that would be racism
poorer white man i know
[Laughter]
no uh where did you grow up with a bunch
of mexicans or blacks
uh
muslims actually what the [ __ ]
italians yeah my best friend uh they
were mobbed up and i didn't know until
years later
yeah
wow i'm glad you weren't mean to them
that's where i get it from
um so
you're mexican he's from the other side
of the railroad tracks well i always say
that
when if i don't have a ring in my my
finger finger i'm i'm free oh
[Music]
well you know you are latin american and
you hate drama so i'm sure
i'm sure that's where it comes that
works out but um yeah i mean uh as
beyonce said if you like it then put a
ring on it exactly
or put a green card on it
uh but i hope that uh you get to stay
here for a little bit you know i hope
you don't get deported and have to use
like a little
metallic blanket um
to go to sleep
no um but uh yeah i hope your boyfriend
wipes you up he's like a tech bro from
austin who's really nice so i'm sure how
did you guys meet did we already ask
that a bumble
oh [ __ ] the dating app started yes
yeah
it was super clear in the in the in the
profile saying like if you're not
pretending to have a family in the
future don't text me i was like oh okay
calm down guy so i text him anyway and
works well he doesn't want a family he
wants a family
like if you don't want thinking to have
a family in the future don't text me oh
wow he's trying to put it in you and i i
honestly just text him for fun because i
was war i was running in the in the lake
and then i was like okay let's have some
some fun and then looking at me i'm here
in a relationship serious relationship
so how many weeks long are you
almost a year if he proposed right now
you've been incubating it
a year
where's that baby going
you're gonna breathe the next lebron
james in there
um but yeah thank you for uh coming to
america and uh having babies with our
american men you know maybe in the
future not right now
that's awesome you know if he proposed
right now what would you say no
oh wow
i mean she is on a date with you so
yeah the standards are pretty to be
honest oh my god that's funny mexican
women you know they know what they want
and they can boss us poor little white
men around why do you refer yourself as
white just now listen to how i talk i
heard him play wonder wall last night so
he gets the white card pass
i know whose side i'm on in the race
wars you know it's back to blue
um but uh thank you
rodney thank you guys
we're coming out tonight we got to see
them date each other
all right
a texas story
let's do the uh lgbtqia plus bucket
we got uh
we got so that's like
everything shauna
coming to the stage
hopefully this is a lesbian lady i hope
it's a man that used to that wants to be
a woman and went from sean to shauna
and trey
trey where's trey at
trey
where are you at trey
wait how are we doing lbtq but we're
gonna uh he's a gay man
i'm sorry trey
i know you love dicks in your ass but we
gotta get this lesbian with another
[ __ ]
i'm sorry trey uh you're gonna have to
suck a [ __ ] later tonight i know you're
gonna have jizz running down your
mustache uh or your chin strap or
whatever a heather
is the other lesbian is there any other
lesbians here
trey you're coming up and dating a
lesbian
there we go
here we go
trey with an a trey
hopefully the carpets match the villains
you could tell how gay this date was
they high-fived each other
give it up for trey and
shauna shauna
[Music]
let's see how you guys mingle with the
opposite sex hi how are you good how are
you i'm with shawna down there too hey
shawna
no no no no so is this your partner back
here that's my wife why is where today
is our anniversary happy anniversary
wow
sorry sorry okay start over
anyway
so have you ever uh
dated a
straight dude i have good i figured
probably and it was not a good
experience terrible yeah i know
um
how long have i been married four years
i've been married 34. oh
so there you go how about that
in others
is this a little like frisky like
anniversary dare you guys hey if this
isn't working out in four years we're
gonna spice this [ __ ] up
what's going on
and 34 years you gotta wanna spy some
[ __ ] up
you guys wanna throw some tajin in there
or whatever
[Music]
oh
yeah whatever this is great this looks
like a scene from any motorcycle bar in
the country right now
you're a trucker you just look like it
uh
motorcycle yeah i knew it
nailed it
i mean you're not even going bald and
you shaved your head that is so true
you are identifying as people that you
are not you sign up for that
yeah that's true that's true
very confusing man this tray i don't
know what's going on with it we call it
complex
i was just in new york city by the way
oh where are you that was awesome oh
what were you doing there i was trying i
was going to see broadway shows uh-huh
that's what all bikers do yeah
he's going to see broadway shows he's
going on dates with lesbians that are
married i've been listening to nothing
but book of mormon since i got back
oh [ __ ] he wants multiple wives that's
what's going on then okay
now we figured it out
yeah that's what i go to texas for is
all the lesbians
they have here why did you go to san
francisco
homosexuality is not a big thing in
virginia beach virginia oh wow it's a
military
well norfolk yeah virginia beach i
thought that was the name of a woman's
[ __ ]
you uh stayed staging d-day landings on
virginia beach right now
that would be dick uh v-day okay all
right
vd day
um i'm sure none of you uh
have aids
but uh
they signed up for the lgbtq market i'm
making age jokes i'm sorry for to the
community trey uh
how how did you uh what did you think
about the uh aids pandemic when it was
going on
i was around it was a thing yeah dallas
buyers club kind of scary right that's
when you grew out your chin strap that's
true yeah i don't know that's a weird
thing to be talking about
i wasn't there i was like a two-year-old
baby when that was happening i just
want to get some historical knowledge
yeah the ones that didn't really affect
real people
like straights
yeah no i love the gays
um
make that clear did you did you help
make the quilt or you're you're more of
a hands up motorcycle guy you know i'm
willing to make a quilt
if it comes to that sure
ladies
he's willing to make a quilt we got a
sewing machine at home i can make it
happen this is not a normal no biker
broadway plays in quilts uh
what anymore
well you got a dui or some [ __ ]
she's got a resting dui face right no
she's she's a she the only reason why
she's saying that [ __ ] is because she
got a scooter
and i and i sold my that is like a [ __ ]
motorcycle oh [ __ ]
the lesbian's telling you how to be a
woman
that's true that's true but i did sell
my bike no offense what are you lick
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] scooter
you gotta scissor your your mode of
transportation like motorcyclists do
what do you drive
shauna i am selling my f-350 diesel i
knew it was a truck i knew it was a
[ __ ] truck texas lesbians are a
different breed
downgraded i got a fourth i got a
forerunner dang oh mine's in the shop a
4x4 4runner why didn't you go with the
classic subaru
[Laughter]
no i'm uh no you like to haul you like
that towing capacity yeah
so who wears a pants in your
relationship you were your wife um we
both do and
we both tell each other how to put them
on and put them off
oh [ __ ]
that's really cool who wear white to the
wedding though
neither one
remember that's not a good time that's
not a good thing he doesn't remember how
old how old are y'all
oh
i might be about to be uh am i about to
be taught about world war ii right now
um i'm 32 right it's been longer than
you've been alive and you're about to
say 25 no really
okay so it's been 30 whatever years and
i don't believe it's been a long time
how old are you dude i thought you were
like [ __ ] 50 30 or 40.
55. wow an elder
oh what right a biker oh my god a biker
and a pastor that is fabulous
what are they what are they gonna think
about you when they see this footage of
you going on a date with a lesbian right
i will get so many kudos you don't know
no i don't know okay but okay
he's a pastor and obviously he's lgbtqia
friendly so that's the kind of church
you want to go to right
yeah
i don't know a pastor that uh is down
with making quilts and going to broadway
plays it sounds like he's really pushing
the gay down that's why i don't know i'm
just saying it's fine it's all good i'm
not i'm not
i'm not frightened by
your
whatever
he's not fooled by you brian bayer
i don't have that no i don't have that
he's not closeted he's not repressed he
loves [ __ ]
and he never thinks about sucking dick
not even once not even the cop
why i have this
keeps it away from all the jokes well
yeah i mean uh you know our uh
hedonistic you know secular ways are you
know a temptation but you know i'm sure
you're good at you know rejecting you
know the outside world you know you're
like supposed to be of this world but
not from this world hillsong that's why
i knew skillet
skillet i'm talking about
that's why
[Laughter]
what's your religious status are you do
you go to church regularly i used to
and i am um i bel i uh
oh wow does she lick it like it's terry
black's
who
it's a restaurant it's a barbecue right
terry black i don't like terry black
barbecue
[Music]
does she look at like it's arugula or
kale or whatever lesbians eat
massage quinoa
some of that sweet quinoa
anyways
sorry uh that we uh you know picked on
uh the lgbtq tonight
um thank you guys so much for signing up
you guys were a great date good job
we love the other shawna as well shauna
number two pastor rodney smith
and shawna
all right oh still inshallah
allah akbar
um thank you guys for coming that was a
date uh next up we got a very special
date we got
sam kuiper the cameraman
here they come
natalia from the crowd
with the disney cruise princess
and
the guy that got assaulted yesterday
sexually
a rape victim over there
uh sam kuiper and natalya the chairs are
moved
and start your date thank you
hi hi
um i'm sam
i'm natalia nice to meet you i love your
accent thank you thank you um where are
you from i'm from puerto rico
are you guys from puerto rico
oh thank you thank you
your accent though how long have you
been in america i've been
in america since i was born
but i moved to texas when i was 20. oh i
thought you said you were born in puerto
rico and then no no i was born in
louisiana but oh i'm sorry i
misunderstood yeah don't call me
racist this lady out there hating on me
right now this is from the crowd
um i misunderstood i'm sorry no that's
fine i thought you said so anyway my
point was i like your accent that's what
i was getting into it's uh it's so cool
thank you yeah um now i'm up here
thinking too hard uh
so
um
how which
you don't live in austin right no i
don't
and you
visit here a lot
i used to so i went to college in san
antonio and then i just moved i
graduated
in the summer so i moved back home to
mcallen and now i've been here for like
a week and a half and i don't think i'm
leaving anytime soon and time give it up
for natalia and sam
she's trapped here she doesn't have a
green card i'm trapped i have the green
card i mean
she's from here
apparently
so were you born in puerto rico or in
america no i was born in louisiana but
my family's from puerto rico okay
someone said cajun who called that was
that one of you guys
that was a good call so that's that's
just how you talk even though you were
born here you talk like you don't speak
english that well well because my family
speaks spanish yeah oh that's my first
language i thought it was because you're
from louisiana and you're [ __ ] i
left like two weeks later
i feel like she just turned off her
accent a little bit right there yeah
she's code switching wow if you start
talking beautiful accents on this show
how do you say new orleans how do you
say new orleans
new orleans
yeah that was like new orleans people
say like knowledge or something yeah but
like i just didn't know if like your
accent and you anyway no
you did it i was just trying like i
don't know how to i was trying to
imitate it no i mean i find that uh on
dates like talking about the accent is
usually like to hack because they hear
it all the time so i try not to go for
that but yeah but has anyone ever asked
you to say new orleans before no never
original hunt wow you're blowing her
mind right now oh my gosh look at that
creativity coming out of the sand
he's behind the camera and not in front
of it
um sam where are you from you have a
weird accent yourself i'm from alabama
oh wow you guys are both so you guys are
basically cousins yeah
hopefully you know what i'm saying
hopefully hopefully
oh [ __ ] okay
weird alabama yeah i moved a lot so i've
lived in uh alabama till i was 10
indiana until i was 20.
and then i uh enlisted in the military i
went to california until i was 30 and
now i'm here i'm 32. by the way so i've
lived a lot of places i've been can't
wait to see where he goes when he's 40.
i know right yeah every decade i might
be leaving uh before then back to
california but that's a
different story
he looks like uh trey in the past he
looks like 20 years ago
oh
i mean he has a lot of hair
trey still has i can see his hairline
from here he's still got a lot of hair
we talk about that just
thick yeah
he's appropriating bald culture yeah
do you have to shave every day
you shave it every day
okay
yeah he wants to appear cool to the
youth kids
natalia what do they do in puerto rico
are you catholic or do you worship the
sun god
yeah i'm catholic
i was born catholic you were born
well i was like i had my like i was
baptized catholic and then like i never
had my first communion though so like
oh so you're going to hell like you know
what i mean like i started off
catholic
but then i just like you know i just you
just stopped i just stopped yeah so like
you know
i'm baptized though what are you talking
about
uh sam so you're not religious anymore
you've uh no uh
it's com i guess like
agnostic right like i believe there's
something i don't just put a label on it
like okay so my the way i say that is
because like think about like extreme
like christian like the crazy christians
and then think about like extreme
muslims the crazy muslims and it's like
they believe that [ __ ] like for real
believe that [ __ ] and opposite so it's
like yo like i agree there's something
like be grateful and be a good person
and all that [ __ ] but like
just [ __ ] get along is all i'm saying
it don't matter you know that's all i'm
saying so i like to just take a step
back and be like
be neutral
acid before this
he's blowing all our minds
but yeah that's my take on religion i
don't like to talk about it though
because people get so
like defensive and uptight it's just
like
not me brother it's a tricky subject
yeah so especially being on stage
talking about religion right and it's on
[ __ ] youtube right now
jesus
yeah let's not talk about religion
well i think i diverted
what do you think about all these
america you're from louisiana so is it
like
pretty different being you say you go
home to macalester so your family moved
to texas yes yes i want to say
i was born in louisiana but i haven't
been there back so i don't know anything
about louisiana so you're a texan yeah
where's mcallen i heard that's like
dangerous way down south yeah it's like
border with reynosa
mexico
she's puerto rican it's a relief we've
had a lot of parents a single person
we've had on the show so far
true when was your last relationship
um
two years ago yeah okay what are you
looking for that was during the pandemic
yeah before the pandemic did you get
coveted and you're like i can't deal
with this yeah he got stuck in mexico
and i was like oh [ __ ]
that's true love right there
she'll abandon you at a moment's notice
sam have you ever got covered i don't
think so i've been tested a bunch i've
got like
like sick
but i've never tested positive so i've
probably been tested today if you can't
if you don't test at all you can never
test positives
alabama methods what he says about stds
too yeah
that's true well until you get like a
visual sign you'll be like well i can't
[ __ ] the lord blesses us with a
visual sign
he's like i'll ignore the game i'll
believe in god then
i'll ignore the itching and burning but
until i get a visual sign then i'll know
it's real
he's a clean man he's an alabama cleaner
i am a clean man though
well uh what do you what are you looking
for in a guy
um
i guess someone someone someone who can
make me laugh
very chill so han someone could make you
laugh
so like a cat video or
[Laughter]
maybe i like cats
you're looking for someone that's uh in
the jets
and you're in the sharks
and
the what
west side story oh i watched it recently
i love portraits on hbo right now you've
been yeah you've been
since college and then in high school
you know what i'm saying so like she
didn't really experience life yet so she
told me she was like you know what you
want you know those 33 year olds so nice
i was like you're a little old to be
[ __ ] saying i don't know what i want
that's all i'm saying i was like you
better figure it out she wanted to put
it about town she wanted to uh you know
[ __ ] a bunch of hoes
yeah which is cool so it's uh i don't
care i just said all right that's fine
like i don't
i wasn't like
i told her i was like yo like you're
still sad about it
yes
me
i'm looking for a relationship like like
a real relationship but like uh like
with the right person you know what i
mean like i don't just need a
relationship just to be like happy right
like i can be single i got acid for that
[ __ ] but i'm saying like no but like i'm
really truly looking for like yeah we
get it
you [ __ ] ask this question you're
gonna goddamn hear the answer and now
you guys yeah we don't really care about
you honestly yeah that's natalia's job
we're just here to make fun of you yeah
that's fair
natalia do you think his shorts are too
short or are they what i said they are
just the right length they're just
okay
all right that's how you get through the
swamps in new orleans
way through there way through the water
and my eases because there i was
wading through the water what do you
guys do for work
so i'm not working right now oh she's
looking for a sugar daddy
i just graduated so i'm in the
awkward stage where you're like what do
i do now you're looking to uh
apply for you said you mentioned you're
looking to apply for pt school yeah pt
school physical therapy where did you
apply to ra so i applied in austin san
antonio dallas like across the state and
then out of state too out of school and
you're like i need more kids
yeah crack their backs i don't know
what is physical therapy
is that that's like therapy but for the
body right yeah
so i've got you who about you of all the
ones you applied to though which one are
you hoping first
like truly though like like out of state
yeah i think new york city that's
awesome oh come to new york
yeah feel you
best city out there
yeah if you want to uh get pollution in
your life
and be at the seat of financial evil
i mean there's a lot of better things
new york is cool a lot of puerto ricans
there you'll find it yeah
you could move in you could join the
jets or the sharks
um yeah i love new york you're gonna do
good there you know columbia i don't
know style for it you guys come here
thank you thank you yeah you're ready to
get onto a subway and get yelled at by a
homeless man she looks more like a biker
than trey ever did i know give me a bike
trey is a [ __ ] compared to natalia
trey's back we found you a biker gal
trey you're gonna we got you a ride home
later
[Laughter]
she still has her bike dude
i'm ready to ride
hey
roll the only thing trey's ready to ride
is this like a scooter and the one that
you push manually
he got flip-flops he rides a little
motorized carts at walmart
all right well you guys think um this
could be a match would you guys do you
have anything in common or is this
awkward i mean i don't know i think the
stage is is different you know what i
mean yeah this is my first time
but like i don't know doing something
like this yeah i think you're pretty
cool thank you you too yeah thank you
it's just a jacket
it is yeah i uh i i was actually
thinking this whole time i was wondering
if i could fit it but
i don't think i could i'm going to
stretch it out
i want to steal it it's all i was saying
it's all the jacket so you guys gonna
trip acid later together or what what's
going on
i don't know have you ever done acid no
nothing nothing
not even a puff of
the marijuana
i don't really like it no every time
i've done it i'm drunk so like i always
get crosstalk you really are
not puerto rican yeah you're from
louisiana for sure
what's your favorite drink like type
like tequila vodka whiskey uh i'd say
tequila but like shots or drinks though
yeah but as of late i've been drinking
vodka and i haven't been that hungover
so thank you for supporting ukraine
during this time of crisis
you've picked up a vodka habit you might
change my favorite drink to vodka when
they invaded a sovereign nation
of course tea patties those are yeah
keep it local i love it
um thank you guys for coming out thank
you very special
sam's gonna go back to making sure we
look beautiful on camera
and natalya is gonna go back to
puerto rico
hopefully
we got one more day coming up one more
day the last names of the bucket you
know who you are if you signed up
we got it
[Applause]
[Music]
they don't want to be doxxed please do
not dox all right give it up for cody
and karen
all right
hello
hi uh nice to meet you really nice to
meet you yes
great i'm single too this is great
that's awesome awesome that's what we're
here for how much do you hate having
your name in this modern day i know
every time i introduce myself how to say
i'm not that kind of care i'm the normal
caring i'm not like the crazy lady
i'm good i'm fine
i hear you i i just had a birthday
dinner and my grandmother kept calling
out to the raider the waiter and i just
kept wanting to say just just relax
it's okay i got mashed potatoes instead
of french fries it's fine totally fine
you're still getting it
yeah so um i'm a little nervous here
you're here with that other person um
are you also from mexico no no i'm from
colombia from colombia
she's from mexico i'm from colombia i
emailed her here and
i'm saying
i i'm here from austin
i
haven't um
moved around a lot i've stayed
in my life but i have enjoyed going to
mexico and i want to go to
other south american countries i really
want to do like an amazon
like
what do you call a zipline tour oh
that's cool i think those would be fun
end time
give it up for cody and karen
on paper it sounds like the whitest
couple ever but you guys are both kind
of weird
you're mexican and he's [ __ ] i'm
going to be colombian honestly
[Music]
wait what did i say you said mexican
yeah they're not all the same okay yeah
colombian
it's totally different i'm colombian
what do you want yeah
thank you for pablo escobar and narcos
here
no um i uh love it uh cody you said that
you want to uh go on a tour of the
amazon but you already look like the way
that you do you could have just sat
there and we would have known that
[Laughter]
karen uh
do you have you ever been into the
amazon
uh no no no no i haven't
why not you live right i don't know i
never had the opportunity to go but i
really want to go what would you do what
do people do there they just like look
or smells things oh well people think
like they almost didn't choose like uh
forests just trees but it's actually
like a nice city i've never been there
but the city it's actually yes it's a
small city it's really nice holy [ __ ] i
had no idea the amazon rainforest was
one city yeah i just wanted these people
living there yes i just wanted to go to
one of those touristy cities near the
amazon and get on a bus for 20 minutes
to go into the mountains and
get ripped off by some yeah you're
paying for the experience part of the
experience is being ripped off you know
it's just
that's how you pay back it's called
trickle-down economics
cody have you ever traveled
or yes my my favorite travel location is
actually cozumel mexico
uh i've gone there
four or five times in the last couple of
years um i want to go again sometime
soon i like to scuba dive a lot and in
my opinion that's the best scuba diving
you can get nice nearby
that's pretty nice do you scuba dive or
is that mostly like what white people do
no i want to do it like uh the most uh
thing that i've done like that is like
skydiving
it's easy to swim up you can't do that
when you're falling
yes
it's really crazy but i'll do it again
experience maybe you could take cody
with you where did you go skydiving new
jersey new jersey okay beautiful scenes
of new jersey right there
nothing like almost dying over this i
used to live there i lived there for two
years and then i moved to assume like
six months ago
so because um
that is sony new jersey because you have
the view it's it's really beautiful at
night yeah dinner there yeah the view
but not the smell better than living in
new york and looking at new jersey
getting on a path train
um
cody
where are you
where have you lived in your life
i've lived in round rock hans round
round 30 miles from here oh yeah that's
where my airbnb is
that is a far airbnb yeah yes oh [ __ ]
any anywhere else besides a 40-mile
radius from here
uh not unless you count camping
cody's an austin native
cody looks like he always camps that's
all
you look like you're homeless
oh i was mistaken for a homeless man
once buy another homeless man it was an
awkward a game-recognized game
[Laughter]
you seem okay with that though
it was it was weird it was a little
humbling it made me more aware of the
homeless people and their their needs
and how they're just people too you're
like no i just drink kombucha it's okay
i'm just stealing your fashion
it was the jacket at the time he wanted
to come into a place i was volunteering
at and they were like no we're closed
he just pointed at me and said but he's
here why can't i be here
i got a haircut the next day
so have you ever dated like a hippie
like you know
loser i mean not a loser i mean he looks
really nice really cute actually he's a
nice guy yeah yes but you uh mostly date
like macho colombian men who can like
you know
um i'm not no no i've been dating white
guys as well so
oh yeah you just went through a breakup
she's drunk
when did you break up with a guy listen
to her
break
a revenge i know it was like um
it was like uh what like three months
ago
it was a guy from scotland
and so what is scotland it's calling so
yes also he wore skirts and [ __ ] and he
wasn't yes
so i said oh my god i don't want and the
last year i i met a guy from albany says
i don't want european guys right now so
all albania albania oh okay albany
albany new york
those guys are even worse than guys from
albania yes so i think the american guy
is more like i don't know i don't know
if i'm wrong but they're more like more
focused more like i don't know
focus or [ __ ] you
lesbians are sick of this man [ __ ] oh
the funniest part of that whole bit was
that i was at the renaissance festival
yesterday and i wore a kilt of course
[Laughter]
so now yes i think
i think the american guys it's nice i
don't know if i'm wrong they're nice yes
yeah we are prime nice i try to be
honest
thank you
um yeah i mean usa all the way you know
we got it number one
um
so cody uh what did you say by the way
uh it says you need to let that [ __ ] go
and it attributes the quote to buddha
but i i didn't know the man personally
said that is so obvious
as an asian man
it's like what if i had a shirt with
like jesus being like
i didn't know dog and drive badly you
know
you can attribute any quote you want to
jesus do i didn't know him personally so
yeah
your word the the pastor it's all the
same to me
cody's the uh new cult leader oh god no
he's gonna start a new waco down here
so when's the drum circle cody when uh
when are we coming oh drum circle's
always at midnight
this is legit yeah
it's austin like this it's
it's kind of crazy here
a lot of drum circles i like it i like
hosting
what is what's your favorite thing about
austin have you seen the bats
uh no i haven't no i haven't seen that i
got here like six months ago so
six months ago six months ago yeah oh
welcome to austin where'd you go from
did i miss this from new jersey oh new
jersey so you are just welcome here yes
welcome to your freedoms and uh
liberties you know
can i see your vax card i want to burn
it
um
i know you just you're just kidding i
gotta say happy there
[Laughter]
um
so yeah i mean
a colombian woman with a
you know classic american hippie
like a
[Laughter]
you know ayahuasca you ever thought
about oh she said yes and nadia didn't
even know what
[Laughter]
okay you shouldn't be nervous when you
do ayahuasca though
ayahuasca is cody in your words uh it's
a hallucinogenic um it's if i'm not
totally mistaken more specifically a
spiritual medicine used by the native
american population
uh i haven't personally had ayahuasca
but i'd love the experience
okay so there we go we found your first
date
you guys can just find an ayahuasca
shaman
you can do drugs together in cody's tent
under i-35
good up for cody and
karen
beautiful
all right thank you guys
that was the show thank you guys so much
for coming out we had a great time uh
there's an open mic after this so stick
around this should be a good time
uh how did you enjoy all the couples
that you saw tonight
yeah i um it gave me you know gave me
hope for love you know
really
feel hope because you can do way better
um well granted that like nine out of
the ten were already in relationships um
yeah goes to show nobody gives a [ __ ]
here in austin
yeah if there's no ring it ain't no
thing yeah exactly let's just
lesbians like be you know crossing over
so shit's crazy here man shit's crazy
keep austin weird
give it up for surah from new york city
thank you so much
my name is hans kim thank you guys so
much good night
[Music]
oh that's fine